Egon Rams ist nun bei mir schön dass Sie
da sind hallo schönen guten
Abend schönen guten Abend Frau Junk Herr
Rams ich habe es eben schon angesprochen
die erste Befestigungslinie die wurde
überwunden schauen wir auch zusammen auf
eine Karte dann können wir alle
gemeinsam drauf schauen wo wir uns da
örtlich bewegen es geht um die Region in
zaporija im Süden der Ukraine sagen sie
das ist nun Grund für
Optimismus also mein Optimismus ist nach
wie vor begrenzt aber ich muss sagen von
meinen Gefühlen geht's mir besser als
vor 14 Tagen denn da zeichnete sich ein
solcher Erfolg nicht ab und es ist
wichtig dass die erste
Verteidigungslinie überwunden worden ist
weil ich auch davon ausgehe dass die
nachfolgenden auch von den Russen
ausgebauten Verteidigungslinien a von
der Anzahl der Soldaten und B auch von
der Stärke der Befestigung
wahrscheinlich nicht so stark sind wie
die erste Linie wir hatten jetzt im
Vorfeld auch Kontakt mit dem
Militärexperte Brady affrick der
Satellitenaufnahmen entlang der Front
auswertet der hatte uns gesagt das was
er sieht in diesen Bildern auf diesen
Bildern ist das jetzt danach nach eben
dieser ersten Befestigungslinie in der
zweiten und dritten dass es da doch
etwas ausgedünnt aussieht was würden Sie
sagen hat Russland genug Material genug
Menschen dass sie genau diese
Verteidigung diese abwehrder
aufrechterhalten können wie sie es
bislang gezeigt
haben sag mal wird Russland davon gehe
ich aus in der ersten Verteidigungslinie
die Masse des Personals eingesetzt haben
und wird auch dieses Personal mit
entsprech dem artilleriefuer und dem
Einsatz anderer Waffen unterstützt haben
wenn die russische Seite in der ersten
Verteidigungslinie entsprechende
Verluste gehabt hat dann kann es
durchaus sein dass für die zweite und
dritte Linie dann Personal fehlt und das
heißt dass die die Linie dann die
nachfolg Linien dann nicht mehr so stark
besetzt werden können wie es die erste
war die Verluste werden sich auswirken
und Russland hat glaube ich so ein
bisschen Personalprobleme auch mit Blick
auf die Soldaten obwohl die Russen
insbesondere im Osten also nicht dort wo
wir jetzt drüber reden äh das Personal
ständig und über den ganzen Sommer hin
verstärkt hat und die russische
hauptabwehrlinie auch das haben wir in
der Karte eben schon gesehen können auch
gleich noch mal drauf schauen die liegt
aktuell südlich vom kürzlich befreiten
Ort robotine wie sieht es denn dort aus
wie haben wir uns das vorzustellen auf
welche Herausforderungen trifft die
ukrainische Truppe
dort also die ukrainische Truppe wird
wenn Sie diesen Angriff weiter nach
Süden fortsetzt und das davon gehe ich
aus wird sie tun äh wieder erneut auf
große Minenfelder wieder erneut auf die
zweite möglicherweise dritte russische
Verteidigungslinie und äh der Kampf wird
für die Ukrainer in ähnliche Art und
Weise weitergehen bis die Durchbrüche
entsprechend erweitert werden und die
Ukrainer dann auch die Möglichkeit haben
nach Überwinden der Minenfelder dann
entsprechend ihre schweren Waffen
einzusetzen es gibt eine erste Frage aus
dem Stream von User Mario er schreibt
ist es Wunschdenken dass die Ukraine
kurz vor dem Durchbruch steht oder was
spricht wirklich
dafür also ich teile diese Auffassung in
gewisser Art und Weise ich sag dir ja
ich bin etwas optimistischer als vor 14
Tagen
dieser erste Durchbruch bei opertine ist
ein erster Erfolg und es geht jetzt für
die Ukraine darum mit prechenden Einsatz
von Soldaten aber auch von Material
diesen Durchbruch oder diesen ersten
Durchbruch entsprechend auszuweiten
ich glaube dass in den letzten Wochen in
den Medien sehr viel von der stockenden
Großoffensive berichtet word ist sodass
das Risiko dass dieses jetzt zu einer
Art Wunschdenken wird dass es jetzt
zügig vorangeht relativ groß ist also
wir sollten in den nächsten Tagen
nächsten Wochen sehr sorgfältig das
beobachten und abwarten wie sich die
Lage dort weiterentwickelt und ich
möchte dazu auch keine Vorhersage machen
weil ich dazu nicht in der Lage bin wir
haben eben gerade als sie auch
geantwortet haben noch mal die
detaillierte Karte gesehen denn weiter
südlich von dem befreiten Ort von
robotine liegt der Ort tokm gilt als
strategisch wichtig tokmar liegt auch
auf dem Weg zum Meer theoretisch
natürlich wenn man dadurch käme wie viel
Gelände müsste man hier denn
zurückerobern müsste man die Stadt
tokmark wirklich zurückerobern um einen
Erfolg zu
erzielen also tockmar ist ein
strategisch wichtiger Punkt weil sich
dort viele Straßen kreuzen auch eine
Eisenbahnlinie in der Nähe vorbeigeht es
heißt aber nicht dass man dann die
Ortschaft tokm entsprechend erobern muss
man kann auch tockmark wenn das geht
einkesseln und kann möglicherweise diese
Ortschaft auch mit Feuer beherrschen ich
weiß nicht welche Planung die Ukraine in
dieser Richtung hat
das bleibt abzuwarten wieder und wird
sich in den nächsten Wochen sage ich mal
vorsichtigerweise entscheiden wie die
Ukraine dort weiter vorgehen wird
Norbert Kranz möchte gerne dazu wissen
jetzt können die Ukrainer die Linien
doch von den Seiten aufrollen und den
Durchbruch weiter ausweiten
oder also wenn die Ukrainer die
Möglichkeit haben beispielsweise
Minensperren zu umgehen und in die
Verteidigungsstellung nicht nicht von
frontal anzugreifen sondern von den
Seiten her anzugreifen dann werden sie
das sicher machen der ukrainische
Generalstab aber auch die örtlichen
Kommandeure der ukrainische Streitkräfte
haben eigentlich in den zurückliegenden
fast anderthalb Jahren unter Beweis
gestellt dass sie in der Lage sind die
Gunst einer bestimmten Situation für
sich auszunutzen und ich gehe davon aus
dass sie das auch weitermachen werden
ich möchte aber ein kleines aber
dahinter hererhängen
wenn wir sehen wie die Russen im
vergangenen Jahr nach der Umgruppierung
der Kräfte in den Osten also etwa ab
April Mai im Osten agiert haben dann
müssen wir auch feststellen dass die
russischen die russische Führung
offensichtlich in diesen zurückliegen
ein viertel Jahr auch gewaltig dazu
gelernt hat das heißt die russische
Seite hat eine Lernkurve gemacht die
möglicherweise auch den Russen erlaubt
dann die entsprechenden Gegenreaktionen
zu ergreifen und auch dieses bleibt
abzuwarten ob sich das so entwickeln
wird oder ob die Ukrainer tatsächlich
wieder wie im vergangenen Jahr einen
taktischen Vorteil erringen können jetzt
hat die Ukraine da im Süden ja wie eine
Art in die russische Befestigungslinie
getrieben gibt's da nicht auch die Sorge
dass man dann von den Flanken wenn man
sich das bildlich vorstellt auch wieder
angegriffen werden
könnte ja das ist ein wichtiger Punkt
den sie da ansprechen wenn ich tief in
die feindlichen Linien eindricke
eindringe kann ich auch von den Flanken
aus durch den Feind entsprechend
bekämpft werden das eine ganz allgemeine
Regel das heißt die Ukraine kann jetzt
nicht nur nach vorne gucken spricht nach
Süden gucken sondern sie muss auch nach
Westen und sie muss auch nach Osten
gucken um zu vermeiden dass die
Flankenangriffe der russischen Kräfte in
ihre Seiten reinbekommt und dann
möglicherweise auch Truppenteile a
abgeschnitten werden bzw durch diese
Flankenangriffe sich in verschiedene
Richtungen verteidigen müssen was dann
auch deutlich mehr Kräfte erfordert
sprechen wir genau das Thema ankräfte
sowohl Menschen als auch Material ich
sehe hier einen Kommentar bei Youtube da
schreibt jemand mal sehen wer die
größeren Reserven hat die Ukraine hat
mit der Offensive zu viele Soldaten
geopfert das wird ihr für den
langfristigen Erfolg zum Problem so die
Meinung eines Users und eine Frage steht
auch noch mit im Stream und zwar möchte
hier der User Dennis wissen wann wird
die Ukraine die zurückgehaltenen
Panzerbataillonen voll in den Einsatz
bringen können wenn wir uns jetzt mal
das Material was die Ukraine hat genauer
anschauen also ich fange mal mit dem mit
dem Thema der schweren Waffen an und wie
man die einsetzen kann diese schweren
Waffen werden erst dann zum Einsatz
kommen können wenn Minen in größerer
Zahl entweder beseitigt geräumt oder
gesprengt worden sind weil sonst die
Panzer im Prinzip wie auf einer Linie
einer hinter dem anderen fahren und
damit natürlich für die russische Seite
leichte Ziele werden das heißt die
Angriffe müssen breiter gemacht werden
und das verlangt dass die russische
verteiligungslinie nach Osten und nach
Westen noch ein in deutlichem Maße
weiter bekämpft wird um auf diese Art
und Weise schwere Waffen auch zum
Einsatz bringen zu können das ist
eigentlich der wichtige Teil dabei
zu dem Thema Personal und Ausrüstung ja
ist richtig dass auch die Ukraine
erhebliche Verluste gehabt hat auch beim
Personal aber ich erlaube mir den
Hinweis dass auch die russische Seite
Personal Probleme hat man hat ja das
Alter für die Wehrpflicht raufgesetzt um
wieder neues Personal rekrutieren zu
können und das ist ein Zeichen dafür
dass Russland ebenfalls personelle
Probleme hat das ist der eine Punkt
dabei und der zweite Punkt dabei ist
dass die ukrainischen Soldaten die
ukrainischen zuchtführer Kompaniechefs
und
batallonskommandeure ihre Soldaten
wesentlich ich sag das mal Personal
Schoner einsetzen und darauf achten dass
Ihre Verluste nicht zu hoch sind das ist
auf der russischen Seite bisher noch
nicht wahrzunehmen von daher hat
hinsichtlich der Verluste an Menschen
die Ukraine einen eindeutigen Vorteil
bei Material sieht das möglicherweise
etwas anders aus und ich muss da
deutlich den Punkt machen die Ukraine
hängt von der Unterstützung aus den
westlichen Ländern ab und ich nehme nur
als Beispiel das Thema Kampfpanzer
Leopard 1 A5 das erste Mal öffentlich
erwähnt am 18 neen vergangenen Jahres
bei einer Talkshow die Entscheidungen
diesen Panzer abzugeben sind gefallen
januarfebruar und wenn man kennenstand
richtig ist haben wir bisher zehn von
denen geliefert und das ist eigentlich
deutlich zu wenig das heißt in diesem
Bereich leidete die Ukraine not die im
Prinzip nur dann abgemildert werden kann
wenn wir westlichen Staaten a schnelle
Entscheidung fällen und dann auch mit
den entsprechenden Mitteln dafür sorgen
durch den standsetzung beispielsweise
dass diese Entscheidungen auch
entsprechend schnell umgesetzt werden
ich sag das ganz oft das geht mir
bisweilen oder auch in der heutigen Zeit
immer noch zu langsam ein weiter wie ein
weiterer wichtiger Punkt in diesem Krieg
die Ukraine hat keine Lufthoheit setzt
aber immer mehr Drohnen auch
selbstgebaute Drohnen ein darüber hatten
wir auch letzte Woche Freitag in unserem
Stream berichtet wie schätzen Sie das
ein welchen welchen Fortschritt lässt
sich machen mit diesem Einsatz der
drohen eben auch der selbstgebauten
drohen also die selbstgebauten drohen
Drohnen sind ein Punkt der mich in den
letzten erthalb Jahren etwas erstaunt
hat denn die Ukraine hat in dieser
Richtung was die was die Herstellung ich
sag auch mal das Thema Forschung die
Entwicklung und die Produktion dieser
Drohnen angeht auch einen gewaltigen Weg
nach vorne gemacht sie nutzt diese
Drohnen nach meinem Kenntnisstand sehr
geschickt zum Teil auch weitreichendere
Drohnen wobei ich da nicht immer weiß ob
da nicht auch Fake Nachrichten und Fake
News von der russischen Seite mit bei
sind wenn wir über die Angriffe auf
Moskau reden trotzdem die Ukraine setzt
diese drohen geschickt ein und auch für
ich sag das Aufklärung und Bekämpfung
der russischen Truppen und sie ist da
drin sehr geschickt wie bewerten sie
denn die Taktik der letzten Wochen und
Monate was hat sich als positiv erwiesen
wo gab es vielleicht Fehler und hohe
Materialverluste also die Taktik der
Ukrainer war im vergangenen Jahr und da
möchte ich gerne anfangen eine sehr
geschickte weil sie immer wieder mit
kleinen Anzahlen von Soldaten ich sage
mal Gruppen und Zugstärke also 10 oder
30 Leute die Stellung beispielsweise im
Osten aber auch im Raum kerson
der russischen Seite aufgerollt haben
man hatte offensichtlich zu Beginn
dieser Gegenoffensive vor mit einem
breiteren Ansatz mit Kampfpanzern und
Schützenpanzern vorzugehen und ist dabei
zum Teil in Minensperren reingelaufen
die diese Angriffe gestoppt haben und
die auch Verluste an Menschen Gott sei
Dank relativ wenig aber auch Material
verursacht haben es gab Bilder im Netz
wo man sehen konnte wie sieben schützen
Panzer bretle ihre Kette verloren haben
einer von denen brante dabei war auch
ein Kampfpanzer Leopard und ein Minen
Räumpanzer der vermutlich dieser
verstärkten kompannie vorausgefahren ist
um eine Minensperre zu räumen sie sind
alle in dem Minenfeld liegen geblieben
worauf sich die ukrainische Seite dann
wieder entschlossen hat mit kleineren
Einheiten und mit Infanterie
vorzugehen was natürlich a
zeitaufwendiger ist und B dann
möglicherweise auch für die Soldaten
erhebliche Verluste bedeutet weil sie a
Zeit brauchen dass der der eine Teil
dabei aber auch halt eben nicht unter
Panzerschutz vorgehen können erst wenn
diese Minenfelder tatsächlich freigelegt
sind oder geräumt sind oder man wie der
eine User vorhin gesagt hat von den
Flanken an diese Minenfelder rangehen
kann oder über die Minenfelder hin
weegehen kann hat man möglicherweise
eine Chance die Angriffsgeschwindigkeit
zu erhöhen das was her Hebestreit gerade
gesagt hat ist entsprechend zutreffend
ist auch zutreff mit Blick auf die
Emotionen der Soldaten wobei ich glaube
dass die ukrainischen Soldaten
mittlerweile so viel Kampferfahrung
verfügen auch Soldaten die neu dazu
kommen durch ältere Kameraden
entsprechend dann in diese Situation
reingestellt und entsprechend
unterstützt werden dass die ukrainischen
Soldaten von der Seite her ich glaube
keine emotionalen Verluste haben wobei
auch das ist ein Thema welches
möglicherweise irgendwann während des
Krieges oder nach dem Krieg hinsichtlich
psychotraumatischer Störung noch mal
aufgearbeitet werden muss schauen wir
auch noch einmal auf die russische Seite
und ein User habe ich gesehen hat viele
frag Fragen gestellt ich möchte eine
rausgreifen Ike bei Youtube möchte
wissen was kann die internationale
Gemeinschaft noch tun um die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive noch in diesem Jahr zum
entscheidenden Erfolg zu führen das war
die eine Frage wobei seine zweite schon
auch war dass wir noch mal auf den
Verschleiß der russischen Armee schauen
machen wir das zuerst schauen uns die
russische Seite an und kommen dann zu
dem part was kann die internationale
Gemeinschaft tun was glauben Sie wie
sieht es aus auf der russischen
Seite also feststeht dass die russische
Seite ein erheblich Höh Anteil an
Verlusten sowohl bei Menschen als auch
bei Material gehabt hat als es die
ukrainische Seite gehabt hat die Russen
haben sage ich mal zumindest im ersten
Kriegsjahr ein verschleißkrieg geführt
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste in den
eigenen Reihen an Mensch und Material
von daher ist auch die materielle
Überlegenheit der Russen nicht mehr so
groß die Aussage gilt zum Teil auch für
Munition von daher dort liegt eine
Chance der Ukraine und jetzt kommt
wieder die Kondition wenn der Westen
seine Waffenlieferung aufrecht hält und
dafür sorgt dass die Ukraine in dieser
Beziehung Gefechts und kampffähig bleibt
lange Prozesse der Entscheidungen lange
lieferprozesse und dergleichen oder
lange
instandsetzungsprozesse sind dabei nicht
von Vorteil für die
Ukraine zu der ersten Frage ob die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive dieses Jahr
noch Erfolg hat Frau jung das ist eine
Frage die kann ich nicht beantworten es
tut mir leid ich würde es den Ukrainern
wünschen ich würde mich darüber freuen
wenn sie tatsächlich irgendwann in eine
Situation setzt würden wo sie
raumgreifende Angriffe durchführen
können Richtung asofsch Meer und auf
diese Art und Weise den Anteil der Krim
aber auch Verkehrslinien
Verkehrsknotenpunkte und dergleichen
mehr für die Russen nicht mehr nutzbar
zu machen denn das wäre der Weg den die
Ukraine zum Teil letztes Jahr und in der
Tiefe des Raumes auch schon gegangen ist
die Logistik auszuhungern und auf diese
Art und Weise dann auch die
entsprechenden Konsequenzen bei den
Russen zu verursachen aber ich
wiederhole eine Vorhersage traue ich mir
diesbezüglich was die Zeiten ang geht
nicht zu ja die Frage die stand auch so
ein bisschen im Zusammenhang da möchte
ich gerne noch eine weitere anschließen
was müsste der Westen tun was müsste aus
dem Westen kommen Simon Feldkamp fragt
sich nämlich welche Voraussetzungen
müssen geschaffen werden damit Taurus
Marschflugkörper geliefert werden wir
erinnern uns da wurde ja schon öfter
drüber diskutiert er schreibt noch
weiter könnte es sein dass man der
Ukraine zutraut bis zur Krim ohne diese
überhaupt durchzustoßen wie sehr braucht
es also vielleicht für einen Erfolg die
Taurus
Marschflugkörper
also Taurus marschfuchkörper könnten
beispielsweise auf entsprechende
Entfernung auf die Krim wirken aber das
kann man auch mit anderen Waffen
erreichen beispielsweise mit den
berühmten heimß Raketenwerfern der
Amerikaner und dafür ist nach meinem
kennnisstand genügend Munition da von
daher das ist nicht unbedingt Taurus
aber Taurus ist eine Waffe die in die
Tiefe des Raumes wirken kann mit einer
Reichweite von 500 km Plus von daher
würde das die Qualität bei bestimmten
Dingen schon verändern und die
Diskussion die zurzeit bei uns in
Deutschland geführt wird ob man den
Ukrainern dafür äh die Waffen geben darf
und sich auf das Wort der Ukrainer die
nicht auf russischen Boden einzusetzen
verlassen soll oder ob man sich
technisch Rewe reichweitenmäßig begrenzt
das ist eine Diskussion die halte ich
ein bisschen für irrational wen man den
Ukrainern wirklich alles geben sollte
was ihnen hilft diesen Krieg erfolgreich
weiter vtzuführen was ja auch in unserem
Interesse ist denn wir müssen immer
daran denken dass auch unsere Freiheit
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Menschenrechte äh
durch die ukrainischen Soldaten und die
ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung in der
Ukraine verteidigt werden und wie das
weitergeht wenn Putin Erfolg hat ist
ebenfalls eine Vorhersage die ich nicht
machen kann wo aber aus meiner
ehemaligen Wirkungsstätte Polen oder
beispielsweise aus den baltischen
Staaten die Befürchtungen dieser
Richtung doch relativ groß sind das ist
ein Grund warum die genannten Länder in
den letzten Tagen wieder entschieden
haben ihre Unterstützung für die Ukraine
finanziell aber auch waffenmäßig weiter
zu intensivieren und fortzusetzen das
gleiche würde ich mir auch von anderen
wünschen
schauen wir jetzt nach vorne schauen wir
auf es wird passieren natürlich
irgendwann der Wetterumschwung den
Herbst zunächst einmal natürlich welche
Herausforderungen bieten sich dann oder
stellen sich da in dem Gebiet in der
Region saporija wo eben aktuell so
heftig gekämpft
wird also dieser Raum südlich von
robotine ist ein Raum der sehr tief
liegt fast auf Höhe des Meeresspiegels
der der Schwarzen Meeres und der nur
nach Osten eine hö Quelle hat und nach
Westen allerdings weit weg eine
höhenschwelle hat das heißt der hat eine
Wirkung wie eine Schüssel wenn wir
starke Regenfälle kriegen dann läuft
dieses Gebiet durchzogen von vielen
Flüssen durchzogen von vielen Gräben
teilweise Sumpfgebiete schlicht und
einfach voll und dann kommt praktisch
jede Bewegung mehr oder weniger zum
Stillstand das wäre eine ausgesprochen
ungünstige Situation und würde dann auch
in der Konsequenz bedeuten dass der
Krieg im Prinzip im nächsten Jahr weiter
fortgeführt wird mit Ausnahme der
Bewegung die vielleicht noch ermöglicht
werden können wenn man starken Frost hat
aber auch da muss man dann abwarten wie
das Wetter weitermacht das heißt man
wird stark abhängig von den
Witterungsbedingungen und das ist dann
möglicherweise für die Ukrainer in
einigen Bereichen nicht von Vorteil
während die Russen dann in ihren
Verteidigungsstellungen sicherlich auch
kein komfortables Leben haben aber dort
halt eben den Witterungsbedingungen
nicht so ausgesetzt sind wie die
Ukrainer die sich in diesem Gelände
bewegen müssen und sie sprechen es an
die russische Seite also womit muss man
vielleicht rechnen dann jetzt auch in
den nächsten Monat en wenn das so kommen
sollte muss man damit rechnen dass sich
auch die Russen wieder versuchen mehr
einzugraben oder ist das eben auch im
Winter gar nicht denkbar was glauben Sie
was was da zu erwarten
ist also wenn sie starken bodenfost
haben wird das mit dem eingraben ein
bisschen schwierig wenn sie starken
Reben Regen haben auch weil ihn dann die
gegrabenen Schützengräben vollaufen mit
Wasser das ist dann für die Soldaten die
dort verteidigen sollen auch nicht
unbedingt eine angenehme Situation und
dann gilt das was vorhin gesagt worden
ist vom Thema Erkältung auf die
ukrainischen Soldaten in gleicher Art
und Weise auch für die russischen
Soldaten da muss man einfach drauf
hinweisen äh trotzdem hat der
Verteidiger in einer solchen Situation
hat er Vorteile wenn der Angreifer sich
nicht mehr bewegen kann weil das Gelände
und das Wetter ist nicht mehr zulassen
dann wird die Sache für die Ukrainer
schwieriger und da haben die Russen
möglicherweise Vorteile vielleicht noch
eine weitere Anmerkung dazu die Russen
haben offensichtlich ihren Schwerpunkt
in den Osten gelegt sie versuchen ja
auch dort wieder Richtung kupjansk und
anderen Bereichen Raumgewinne zu
erreichen und ich vermute das muss ich
allerdings auch so sagen ohne zu
spekulieren dass die Kräfte die im Süden
angesetzt sind
dann nicht ausreichend werden auf der
russischen Seite wenn die Ukraine
tatsächlich die Möglichkeit ihren
Angriff erfolgreich fortzusetzen was wie
ich vorhin gesagt habe auch von uns
abhängt
ich möchte einen Hinweis geben Thema
Luftüberlegenheit
der russischen Seite ja das ist der
Grund warum die ukreine so intensiv nach
den F16 fragt ähm es ist aber auch
positiv zu vermerken dass in den letzten
in der letzten Woche die ersten großen
Lieferungen an Munition für den
flagpanzer geppard beispielsweise
geliefert worden sind und damit die
Luftverteidigung mit dem flagpanzer
Geppert gestärkt werden kann ein
weiterer positiver Punkt ist Iris SLM
Iris SLM hat eine ausgesprochen hohe
Abschussquote aber auch dort verfügt die
Ukraine bisher nur über zwei Batterien
und es sollen noch welche geliefert
werden und ich kann nur sagen ich hoffe
dass die bald kommen um auch diese
Luftüberlegenheit auszugleichen F16
werden wir glaube ich in diesem Jahr in
der Ukraine nicht mehr sehen das heißt
da müssen wir uns dann auf das nächste
Jahr konzentrieren neben der Moral der
Truppe ist natürlich auch noch ein
weiterer Punkt wichtig das durchhalte
vermögen und auch die Unterstützung aus
der Bevölkerung der Ukraine die
natürlich Monat für Monat mit heftigen
Angriffen auch jenseits der Frontlinie
zu kämpfen hat wie schätzen Sie das ein
die Unterstützung aus dem Land hält die
weiter
an also ich glaube dass der ukrainische
Präsident selenski sehr sehr stark daran
arbeitet dass diese Unterstützung der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung nicht
nachlässt dafür gibt es auch im Prinzip
ein Beleg es hat Ende August oder mitte
ende August eine Meinungsumfrage bei
repräsentativen Menschen in der Ukraine
stattgefunden und dort STT kommt
eindeutig zum Ausdruck dass dreiviertel
der Menschen dafür sind dass die Ukraine
sich weiter verteidigt dass 90% der
Menschen kein Land der Ukraine an
Russland abgeben wollen von daher das
ist ein eine ausgesprochen positive
Situation die dort ist die natürlich
durch die Angriffe auch von drohen
marschfluchkörpern in der Tiefe des
Landes beeinflusst wird aber auch dort
zeigt die ukrainische Bevölkerung bisher
sehr viel Moral und es sieht nach diesen
Meinungsumfragen und nachdem was man in
Berichten hört so aus dass die
ukrainische Bevölkerung weiter hinter
ihren Truppen hinter ihren Soldaten
steht und die Regierung entsprechend
unterstützt